yesterday i asked you
to roast my facial hair
roast my facial hair not for a video
i said well you've just been played this
is for a video
you've been tricked one of my great old
epic trolls
you fell for it you think i'm scared of
your roasts
you think i'm scared this is the most
pristine
beautiful silky
thing ever and ain't nothing bad you
could say about this
oh let's see what you guys are going to
say oh it looks like pubic hair
you wish you could grow pubic hair like
this oh it looks like someone
killed a cat whatever [ __ ] off okay here
we go let's read what you said
let's read what you said oh i'm so
scared number one
women respectercam
caveman oh no he called me a caveman
oh look at the tears they're just good
that goes and so
caveman if it looks like i'm crying it's
because it's fake
tears did someone say jesus
well that's good to know my beard looks
like jesus christ
i thought this was the roast jesus
christ the most attractive man in
humankind
that's how my beard looks like i'll take
it thank you
oh look we got critical it's actually
him
the real one except he's not verified so
it's
damn it it's not him [ __ ] hair like snow
beard like thorn i want to know when
will you do porn
i don't know when he'll do it but i know
it'll be called
profess do you mean sister fister
mr sister fister legend of the professor
okay but these are your pubes though so
like oh look at that
the pube jokes well done
well done i see it looks like puberty
care
you couldn't grow pubic hair on your ass
oh here we go
[Music]
but brad someone who's torn it
apart
and he's taken just all that i
have but if you wanna try
to love again
[Music]
this is me man why would you what are
you implying here
these two gents have excellent facial
hair okay
a quick roast you asked a quick diss
track you receive
every time that i click on this picture
it makes me wish that i was vision
impaired you straight up put condition
in your hair
take it from a man who grows a beard
that you will always savor i must ask
you a question but i'll be shaving that
for later i'mma roast you harder than
some beef that was left in the yelp and
grow some blaze at your fingers you'll
be wolverine second cousin ain't nobody
told you that no shave is only in
november you got to look like you took a
cat and then shoved it
oh hey look it's the cat comment sorry
limp biscuit
i'm sorry i didn't know you were still
alive limp dickness
[ __ ] [ __ ] you oh okay i see all right
you
you're drawing the the the island he's
lost in an island
uh comparison give tom hanks a nice
outfit you know
suit him up do his hair he'd look
[ __ ] popping
and you know it ouch don't roast facial
hair man
use a razor
can i die now oh here it is you mean
your pubic hair on your face
i hear that
[Laughter]
i can't roast what's already been burnt
listen here listen here you whammon
just cause you're a wham and i'm gonna
go easy on you but you
i bet if you could grow a beard
you look like a little [ __ ]
is keemstar trying to roast my beard
keemstar i thought you were better than
this i have a pretty bad one i could say
but i think it's best if i shave it
oh i get it
no that that's my genuine reaction there
hey
i get it
it looks like something i'd use to scrub
the [ __ ] off my tongue
this is mean it looks like you glued
cubes to your
chin
up bro it looks like it could be its own
person
it's actually kind of cute you may n you
make out with that [ __ ] sexy ass son
of a [ __ ]
let's get real here for a second this is
not a roast this is a
lift me up baby cause you i'm so sexy oh
my god that's disgusting
grow it a bit more and try this what the
[ __ ]
he's eating ramen noodles out of his
okay did you just swap
what the [ __ ] it looks so weird
jesus christ please don't ever do that
again
felix you're not supposed to wear the
hedgehog
it's your face upside down damn you got
more hair below than a pub
listen i ain't balding do you see this
hairline
okay do you see this perfect [ __ ]
it's stronger than a stronger swedish
viking
okay [ __ ] you
man okay ain't no insecurities here
perfect hair perfect facial hair perfect
facial features
a goddamn god likes complex thank you
thank you what the [ __ ] is this
girlfriend magazine
pewdiepie doesn't look like this anymore
don't jump on the hate on the beard
train not girlfriend magazine
okay so they they they picked some of
the best roasts
uh caveman wolverine and uh
wolverine
this is some fine journalism there
oh look brad your feet your feature on
girlfriend magazine brad congrats
a new high for you brad congrats well
done brett
well done thank you
[Applause]
god dammit god [ __ ] damn it i guess
me and [ __ ] brad pitt have the same
god-awful
what the [ __ ] it
no felix don't listen to them your beard
is beautiful
that's better
[ __ ] hell that's disgusting can
someone photoshop away the eyebrows of
that
the ugliest [ __ ] ever
wow what a well-constructed roast really
really hit the nail on that one
deforestation is a serious problem
liked by ecosia the search engine that
plants
trees is this all you got i'd literally
scroll to the bottom okay
yeah wow incredible that's all you had
nothing about how we can't connect
nothing about how there's no grump here
whatsoever
nothing about how there's ginger bits in
there i have
ginger in my dna i discovered it now
but the bearded state that's right i
don't care what your little teenage sons
and [ __ ] think
it's beautiful and the more you all hate
on it the more it grows
for every [ __ ] pose saying [ __ ] please
shave
it gross another centimeter so keep them
coming kids
cause i ain't afraid i'm not insecure
about your [ __ ]
i may have failed last time i may have
given into the pressure
of shaving and that was only because i
was literally [ __ ] kidnapped
it was against my free will for four
months
oh my god that beer did not look good is
it longer now
i must have more testosterone this time
around
[Music]
it is me odin
i cannot let you do this felix i have
watched you look like a little [ __ ]
for 26 long years look at this face
it's pathetic do not listen to your fans
pewdiepie
half of them are clearly [ __ ] half
of them are clearly [ __ ] i do what i
want
i got the most subscribers i'm gonna
shave
fine if you shave
i'll make it so that marzia
won't
because
i'm surprised woolster didn't pick up on
this one to be honest
no no one noticed this one
christ when was this june 2016.
okay let's end the video here thank you
sister fisters
you can keep them coming shave
supporters non-shaped supporters let me
know what in the comments down below
what do you think what are your thoughts
and comments they will have no impact on
my life and the choice
decisions whatsoever leave a like if you
want me to shave and leave a like if you
want me to not shave
thank you guys so much and i'll see you
sisters in another fister